et bien voilà Mesdames Messieurs c'est
le dernier
vous pouvez embrasser votre cavalière
[Musique]
en plus incroyable 1 incroyable
j'ai limite envie de le revoir
ne regardez que le bisou mais en
regardant la meuf derrière
en regardant Nathalie vous ne lâchez pas
Nathalie regardez bien Nathalie sur la
tête de ma mère elle a ce qu'on appelle
un somme non dissimulé
c'est incroyable franchement pour moi
c'est une des plus grosses d'arcade de
l'histoire de l'amour est dans le pré
mechine ça me rappelle Daniel en soirée
regardez
votre cavalière
[Musique]
très dur très très très dur
musquina j'ai envie de dire voilà je
crois que c'est le premier mot qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est fou elle est ivre
de Somme exactement mais c'est vrai ivre
de Somme moi cette émission bon on va
pas j'adore elle est très divertissante
à regarder c'est pour ça que ça cartonne
et moi ce qui me gêne j'en ai marre
arrêtez
on rigole comme si c'était des
personnages de fiction mais à tout le
monde se marre mais le mec vraiment
comme ça dans la vraie vie
non c'est pas moqué de la galette un
jour on montrait un mec qui avait perdu
une dent tout le monde rigolé mais c'est
vrai dans mon gars
il y a un décalage entre les
agriculteurs qui participent au 1er
degré et tout le monde qui regarde au
deuxième
je vais t'appeler Patrick Cohen
maintenant
le roi du seum tu te prends toujours la
tête tu te la racontes tu me fais chier
tu finiras sur France 5 euh sans rien
nous faire chier tu vas finir sur France
5 pour une fois je vais un petit peu
aller dans le sens de Guillaume
de mes émissions préférées vraiment donc
c'est très rare que je la critique mais
là pour une fois je me dis il y aurait
pas eu de caméra est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que cet homme ce serait permis
d'embrasser cette femme
de la bière c'est de l'autre parce que
c'est justement gentleman qui se fait
avoir par les caméras et par la page
et je pense justement que jamais de la
vie il aurait fait cette chose devant la
concurrence alors après ce bisou entre
gens et Laurence l'ambiance n'était pas
de ouf c'était pas la folie mais
heureusement Jean était là pour prendre
ma situation vous allez voir
malaise de ouf
[Musique]
ils ont une grande salle quand même
[Applaudissements]
survêt quoi et on le retrouver samedi
soir à côté de Léa Salamé sur France 2
bien entendu à ne pas manquer quelle
époque les Chéries euh ça c'est
incroyable c'est le meilleur et ça c'est
le meilleur en fait il faudrait tout
revoir il faudrait avoir tous les
extraits de fois non mais celui-là il
faut le revoir parce que regardez on se
dit dans sa tête il cherche regardez
dans sa tête il cherche un bail et
qu'est-ce que je veux dire il y a ça qui
sort quoi il est dans il est il est
Stéphane Plaza regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la pauvre Nathalie que j'embrasse fort
en tout cas c'était trop d'émotion pour
elle elle a décidé de s'éclipser sans
blague et voilà
regardez et on s'éclipse on nous a fait
ce qu'on appelle dans le métier une
Benjamin Castaldi regardez
avec tous les doigts
c'est bon quoi
je regarde pas en fait tu crois que
j'aurais pas
[Musique]
gagné
on est que dimanche
[Musique]
je sais qu'elle gibule là il est dans sa
tête elle rigole quoi
[Applaudissements]
ce qui lui est arrivé je suis à deux
doigts de franchement de lui trouver
quelqu'un
ça va
c'était Géraldine puissance 10
excusez-moi
voilà donc la pauvre c'est cruel c'est
arrivé mais enfin bon en même temps
c'est la revanche c'est la hanche l'eau
qui dort mais fiez-vous de l'eau qui
dort Laurent ça disait rien et hop tout
de suite elle galoche
elle est jolie
les chéris non mais franchement c'est un
des plus grands épisodes de L'Amour est
dans le pré de l'histoire ça a été
repris de ouf sur Twitter c'était la
phrase de la soirée après ça Nathalie a
quand même essayé de bien se vendre
auprès des proches de gens mais c'était
sans compter sur son ancien métier un
peu particulier c'est vrai que voilà les
gens voilà regardez
moi je suis à la plonge et je fais 8h du
matin à 19h je fais la vaisselle fraise
journée et avant j'étais agent
d'entretien je travaillais à la piscine
à chatte et à la piscine je faisais 6
heures 9 heures je travaille à la
piscine à chatte
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que c'est non mais c'est quoi
la piscine achat
S
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]